In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 28, on which we commemorate our righteous mother
Irene of Christovalanto, St. Irene lived in Cappadocia in a rich and noble family.
After the death of the iconoclast emperor, Theophilus in the year 842.
And Thelora assumed the Regency.
She searched the whole empire to find a wife for her son, Michael III, in the years 842 through
867.
Remarked for her beauty and the nobility of her conduct by those sent from the court, Irene
was sent to Constantinople with her sister, who later married Caesar Barthas, Thelora's
brother.
Crossing near Mount Olympus in Bethinia, on the way to Constantinople, she visited St.
Joannicus the Great, who greeted her by telling her that she would become the Abyss of the
monastery of Christovalanto, Golden Purse.
Providence, having prevented her marriage to the emperor, she, with a relieved heart and
full of joy, gave away all her possessions and retired to the monastery founded by the
Petrician Nikitas, Nicholas, near the sister of Aspar.
It was a place where the air was good, far from public squares and noisy places.
At her monastic consecration, the blessed woman not only cut off her hair, but also every
link that attached her to the world and gave herself zealously to ascetic labors, knowing
that, to the measure that the flesh is weakened, the inner man is renewed and draws nearer
to God.
Clothed in a single tunic that she changed once a year and nourishing herself on bread
and water, she gladly submitted to everything that was prescribed for her, far from murmuring
or opposition.
Her constant compunction made her heart glad and was reflected in her face, and like a
fertile land she produced the abundant fruits of Holy Virtue.
She regarded all her sisters as queens and considered herself as their servant, giving herself
over to the viallist of tasks to render them service.
Her mouth spoke only the words from the Holy Scriptures or the Holy Fathers upon which
she meditated constantly.
When she had been less than a year in the monastery, having read with admiration the life of St.
Arsenius, who prayed from sunset until the morning, she undertook to imitate him.
With God's aid, she was able little by little to remain standing, her hands outstretched
in prayer, all day and all night.
She struggled with such discernment to subject her body to her soul's yearning for God,
that no machination of the devil was able to touch her.
When the devil provoked memories of the glory and ease of the life she had left, she went
to confess these thoughts to her abyss and redoubled her eschesees, and she was soon delivered.
At the death of her abyss, she was designated in spite of her own desire to succeed her,
and was consecrated by the Holy Patriarch Methodius.
Remembering St. Johnicus' prophecy, I'm thinking that it was her duty not to seek her own
pleasure, but to carry the weakness of those who did not have her strength.
She lived thenceforth as an earthly angel, prolonging her fasts, praying the whole night
and making innumerable prostrations.
It was by these means that she brought God's blessing down upon herself, and received
such wisdom that she was able to lead numerous souls along the path of salvation.
She asked the sisters to consider her not as their superior, but as one of them who had
been placed at their service.
With gentleness and patience, she exhorted them to conduct themselves in all things, according
to the evangelical precepts.
Rejecting the vain attractions of glory and human esteem, lest they should renounce the world
only in appearance.
They were to take care not only to remain pure, but also to be gentle.
Both virtues, beyond nature, given by Christ to those who pray to Him with faith.
Whatever heights they might reach in virtue, they should consider it as God's gift and
remain in compunction and constant thanksgiving.
Besides this, she forbade them to pray for their health.
For she would say that nothing is so useful to the soul than illness accepted with gratitude.
Having obtained the gift of prescience from an angel, the saint was like a prophet of
God in her monastery.
After taking a little rest after matins, she would call the sisters to her one by one, and
with skill and discernment would help each of them to be pure, and without pretense before
God, revealing their most secret thoughts to them.
She soon became renowned in the whole city for her virtues and the wisdom with which she
governed her community, and all sorts of people, rich and poor, common and noble would come
to her to receive her councils and to confide themselves to her prayer.
To them all, she taught the usefulness of repentance and conversion by which at every moment we
can be made pleasing to God.
And by divine grace, she unceasingly progressed in askesis and pure prayer.
Throughout the great fast until Easter, she ate no bread but only took a small amount of
vegetables once a week.
To keep vigil all night had become as normal to her as sleep was to others, and she spent
all her nights, her hands stretched out towards heaven, absorbed in holy contemplation.
She sometimes remained in this posture for two days and even for a whole week so that
her disciples even had to help her to lower her numb arms.
One night a nun looking into the courtyard saw Saint Irene in prayer, miraculously lifted
from the ground, and the two Cypress trees in the monastery courtyard inclining their
tops to the ground, only sprang back to their normal form after being marked with the sign
of the cross by the Saint.
This nocturnal prayer was terrible to the demons who redoubled their assaults in the middle
of the night, on one occasion one of them through the burning wick from an oil lamp at her.
Irene's habit started to catch fire, but she remained unyielding, and she would have
been reduced to cinders if one of the other nuns woken by the smell of burning flesh and cloth
had not entered her cell, forcing the door.
In the middle of the thick smoke she saw with stupification that the saint was on fire,
still standing impassable in prayer.
Once she shook her trying to put out the flames, Irene lowered her arms and said to her in
a reproachful tone, why have you deprived me of such rejoicing through your impetuous intervention?
An angel was standing before me in the process of weaving me a crown of incorruptible flowers
such that I has not seen, and he was ready to carry me off when you chased him away.
When her disciple peeled away the pieces of cloth that had stuck to her flesh, a wonderful
fragrance filled the whole monastery.
On another occasion a sailor who had come from Patmos presented himself at the monastery and
gave the saint three delicious apples that St. John the Apostle had charged him to deliver
to her.
The first apple suffice to feed her for forty days, during which her mouth gave forth
an incomparable fragrance.
She gave the second to the community on great and holy Thursday and kept the third as
a precious talisman, a guarantee of the incorruptible blessings of paradise.
Through her prophetic spirit, blessed Irene worked many other miracles, and in particular
predicted the assassination of Barthas, followed by that of Michael III in the year 867 and
the seizure of power by Basil the Macedonian.
Assisted by St. Basil the Great and St. Anastasia, Farmacolidria, she healed the possessed
and saved one of her kinsmen, whom the emperor had thought to execute for treason by appearing
to the sovereign radiant with glory.
Emperor Basil recognized his error, asked forgiveness, and thenceforth gave the monastery his benevolent
help.
And Irene lived until she was 103 years old, keeping all her youth and beauty, a sign
of the beauty of her soul.
Her guardian angel warned her of the day of her approaching death, and, when it came, she
gathered together the sisters, designated the abyss whom God had chosen, and, after having
exhorted them to disdain all that was transitory, in order to live with her beloved spouse,
she peacefully closed her eyes and gave her soul into the Lord's hands.
Buried in the chapel of the Holy Marjorie Theodore, her tomb constantly sent forth a fragrant
perfume, thus manifesting to all the favor that she had acquired with God.
And until our own days, Saint Irene has not ceased to intercede for those who invoke
her with confidence.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
save us.